already is pretty compelling obviously
uh we invested
in you know my personal fascination is
just this idea of
uh can you completely disrupt an
industry that is highly highly
profitable by simply
changing the way that you get paid right
and so uh rather than the transaction
fees if you go to the subscription model
uh i ran the math and it's look you know
coinbase would have made more money in
2017
by having everyone pay nine dollars a
month uh that was part of their user
base
rather than have them just make the
billion plus dollars they made on
transaction fees
all right so the subscription model
works in in that sense
now in terms of uh where you guys go
from here
what are kind of other products you're
thinking about other areas that are
interesting and kind of maybe other
bodies of work that uh that you guys may
or may not
end up working on so our mission
is to build the best financial
institution in the world
and a financial institution as a bank
first of all it's a place where you can
collect your paycheck
and and uh you know deposit checks and
basically
be the place you keep your money um but
we think that we think the ecosystem is
rapidly
evolving um and so you know for us to
offer
a bank if we want to launch the best
financial institution
and we didn't support crypto that would
be like launching a new
laptop in 2002 that doesn't support
wi-fi right
um you know or you launched the imac
without connecting to the internet
so it's it's like we fundamentally have
to be part of this this this change
that's going on from sort of government
issued funny money to
to money that we can all really trust
like like we want to bank your money
and bitcoin is better money than cash so
like we're going to bank that right
as we look beyond that and of course we
we have the customer support features
as we look beyond that uh we
are planning to add more states so we
support 60 of the population today
um we expect to support everywhere but
new york
by um early 2021.
uh that's a that is a a an incremental
change and if you sign up now you'll
receive a notification email once your
state is open
the other thing we're doing is we're
offering we're adding by the end of this
year
a debit card and the ability to do
direct deposit
and deposit checks so at that point
what you have is a bank that's
completely at parity
with something like chime or wells fargo
mobile
but is built for you has great customer
support
and and that's where we see people going
basically being able to live off this
product right um
i mean you could you could never deposit
cash once onto this platform
just use it to store bitcoin and pay
your bills with your debit card
um it's just a radically new approach to
banking
and we're in early access now during
early access at the end of the year
those features will be deployed and then
and then we will be a full production
product
um beyond that uh i'd say the major
initiatives that we're looking at is we
would love to support
the eurozone the united kingdom uh
canada new zealand and australia
as a start um because it is our goal to
be the best
financial institution in the world and
the most reasonable place to start is in
financial systems that are a lot like
ours and with customers that have a lot
of the same similar expectations
and the other thing that we'll look at
is adding stocks
i think there's a big opportunity to
make
stock investing better part of it is is
if you want to invest in stocks you need
to move
cash from your bank account into a
brokerage account
and just like we want you to buy bitcoin
right out of your checking account you
ought to be able to buy stocks
right out of your checking account and
then you know that's part of the
motivation
another part of the innovation is we
want to get rid of these hidden spreads
that robinhood charges
um we want to educate the market on that
and and have our customers feel
confident that their subscription
is the only fee that they're paying um
and then the the final part of that
would be taking
autopilot which is our technology for
automating trading today
and and evolving into something that can
manage your whole portfolio
how much bitcoin are you huddling how
much are you
market making with the autopilot do you
have a diversified portfolio of etfs
um you should be able to invest from
your checking account
and liquidate back into your checking
account without leaving the app and have
that investing experience
be able to meet all of the needs as you
invest
you know your your cash for the your
cash or bitcoin money for the future
explain a little bit more about what
autopilot does right now
yeah so um
so at a high level what autopilot does
is it allows you to take
bitcoin that you would otherwise be
huddling and move it into the autopilot
account
and it will automatically invest
those crypt those assets on your behalf
um so how does it invest it
is it like crazy voodoo machine learning
it's not
it's it's doing a process called market
making and market making is one of the
like
oldest most proven and consistently
profitable ways to make money
in all of investing and it follows the
simple
the simple rule of buy low sell high so
a market maker let's say you got
you've got ten thousand dollars of
bitcoin on your account you've got ten
thousand dollars of cash on your account
and bitcoins trading at ten thousand
dollars so what i'm going to do
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take my cash i'm going to offer to buy
at a discount so i'm going to offer to
buy at 99 950.
that means anyone that trades with you
is paying you a 50 profit
for each bitcoin that they buy then i'm
gonna take all my cash
uh sorry uh that's with cash then i'm
gonna take my bitcoin
and i'm offered to sell that at a point
five percent premium so ten
ten thousand dollars fifty dollars and
so um
anybody that buys that you're making
fifty dollar profit
for for the bitcoin um and
uh so what autopilot does is it runs
that strategy
based on the current price estimate from
our partners over economics
and it runs that strategy 24 hours a day
and it reprices your orders every 15
seconds so
this is like a high frequency trading
tool
that is running like a a proven strategy
for consistently earning income
and the way it earns that income is when
people go on our platform
and they just buy or sell using the
standard interface
that's a market order and it's going to
consume some of these
uh amm's liquidity uh and so
um during alpha uh we were
uh we're gonna have to see what happens
during prod like we are we're gonna have
a big birth like a big growth of supply
uh and then while demand is ramping up
or will there be a lot more demand than
supply as
the marketplace balances out but you
know during alpha we were seeing
we're seeing people get about a six
percent monthly return on
their autopilot funds as the while the
markets were active
um the final thing i want to touch on is
it was really important for us to
uh to introduce a a strategy
an automated strategy that lets you
participate in the crypto market but
passively
and we didn't want it to be voodoo so
the specific implementation that we've
made
is uh it's based on state-of-the-art
research
um uh on stochastic optimal control and
it's proven to be the optimal strategy
for market making
it's what the wall street guys are doing
it's what the chicago guys are doing
modern market makers run this algorithm
and we're making it available to
to everyone you can learn more about
this strategy
by clicking the more info button on your
automated market maker and that includes
a link to the research paper where we
developed it
yeah it's really cool i think how what
you're basically saying is you're giving
the market making profit to the user
and also making sure there's liquidity
on the platform right is that
generally correct yes that is 100 it's
both those things
and then also what we're doing is we're
taking
we're taking another one of these hidden
fee business models
and we're getting rid of it because if
you go on coinbase consumer today
you're going to have a uh you're going
to have a commission fee which is 1.5
and then that is subject to a minimum
right 0 to 50 that's a dollar beyond
that it's 2
it goes up to three dollars um so that's
their commission
what they're not telling you is that
they also increase the price
by 0.5 so coinbase is market making
directly to their consumer clients
um we are also eliminating that now
there's still a fundamental need to
market make
and we're going to let our customers
earn the profit by delivering value
market making
but we are removing ourselves as a
market making participant
an intermediary such as coinbase word